[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich habe für euch
einige macken rezepte ausgetestet und
schlussendlich ein richtig richtig gutes
und geling sicheres macao rezept für
euch entwickelt und ganz wichtig ist mir
dabei dass ihr kein besonderes werkzeug
benötigt und auch keine spezial zutaten
ich zeige euch jetzt zuallererst die
zutaten für den teig wir benötigen
eiweiß dazu sage ich euch später noch
etwas puderzucker gemahlene und
broschierte mandeln die findet man
bereits auch in kleineren supermärkten
außerdem zucker und salz zuallererst
werden puderzucker und auch die mandeln
durch ein feines sieb gegeben damit auch
keine klümpchen im teig sind und dieser
schritt ist wirklich sehr wichtig also
lasst ihn bitte nicht aus
[Musik]
die etwas gröberen mannes stücke die vom
sieht aufgefangen wurden die geben wir
dann nicht mit dazu aber wir ersetzen
die menge doch noch mal durch gemahlene
mandeln damit wir auch auf die genaue
gramm zahl kommen dann wird das ganze
einmal schön verrührt und es geht weiter
mit dem eiweiss dazu wollte ich euch
noch was sagen ich habe den tipp von
meiner lieben schwägerin bekommen und
der ist wirklich gold wert sie gab mir
nämlich den entscheidenden tipp dass ich
das eiweiß eine nacht vorher im
kühlschrank lagern soll natürlich mit
frischhaltefolie bedeckt und ich muss
sagen dass die macarons so deutlich
besser wurden
das eiweiß habe ich zusammen mit der
prise salz in einer küchenmaschine
cremig gerührt und an der stelle gebe
ich den kristallzucker dazu
[Musik]
nun wird das ganze weitere zwei minuten
komplett steif geschlagen und dann geht
es auch schon weiter
das eiweiß muss komplett steif sein also
wirklich richtig steif und dann geht es
auch schon weiter mit den trockenen
zutaten denn hier kommt noch farbe mit
ins spiel
ich fülle die puderzucker mandl mischung
hier nur in eine größere schüssel und
jetzt gebe ich noch pulver farben mit
dazu und das liebe ich auch noch mal
damit auch keine klümpchen entstehen
ich habe mich hierfür pastell blau
entschieden nach dem backen waren die
macarons eher pastell grün das hat mir
zwar im endeffekt besser gefallen aber
ich habe mich dann doch etwas gewundert
ich denke einfach dass die
farbkombination blau und dieser
gelbstich von den mandeln dass das
bewegt hat dass die farbe dann doch grün
wurde
nun wird mit ganz viel geduld die baiser
masse untergehoben und zwar so dass ihr
am besten so wenig luft wie möglich da
raus schlag ich weiß es ist schwierig
aber wenn er sich viel zeit lässt und
mit einem teig sauber arbeitet dann
funktioniert das auf jeden fall
auch ein kleiner hinweis für all
diejenigen die gerne mit passten farben
statt pulver farben arbeiten gibt die
pasten farbe dann am besten zur baiser
masse und flüssige lebensmittel farben
eignen sich hier eher weniger denn das
würde die konsistenz verändern
[Musik]
ihr erhaltet dann so eine dickflüssige
konsistenz das wie ein buchstabe v vom
type server herunter fließt und jetzt
ist er teig fertig und wir führen ihn
einmal um in einen spritzbeutel
ein backblech habe ich mit einer dauer
back folie ausgelegt ihr könnt auch
genauso gut ganz normales backpapier
verwenden
ich habe es auch mit einer silikon matte
versucht das falls keine silikon mathe
für macarons sondern die ganz reguläre
und damit hat es nicht so gut
funktioniert die empfehle ich euch
deshalb eher weniger
[Musik]
eine spritztour braucht die hier auch
nicht ihr könnt ganz einfach so wie bei
mir vorne die spitze abschneiden und
dann könnt ihr die kreise ganz einfach
drauf spritzen wichtig ist nur dass ihr
das komplett senkrecht tut also auch
nicht zeitlich sondern wirklich von oben
einmal auf spritzen
ihr solltet auch beachten dass ihr die
macarons mit etwas abstand auf ein
backblech spritzt und ich habe hier wie
ihr seht ihr mini macarons gebacken ihr
könnt natürlich auch viel größere machen
dass es vollkommen euch überlassen und
wichtig ist jetzt damit die kleine
luftbläschen auch noch verschwinden dass
ihr das backblech ein paar mal auf eure
arbeitsfläche fein last
als ihr jetzt noch irgendeine stelle
habt ihr euch nicht gefällt dann könnte
ich hier mit einem nagel ran und die
kleinen unebenheiten einmal ausbessern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
einer der wichtigsten schritte kommt
jetzt wir müssen das blech an einem
kühlen ort eine stunde lang antrocknen
lassen und zwar so dass wir die
oberfläche nach einer stunde so wie hier
jetzt im video anfassen können ohne dass
da was kaputt geht und dann geht das
ganze bei 140 grad umluft zehn bis zwölf
minuten lang gebacken nach dem backen
bitte auch nicht sofort anheben lassen
sie erst mal 15 minuten stehen
und wenn sie dann diese typischen füße
gebildet haben dann sind sie genau
richtig und perfekt weiter geht's mit
der füllung wir benötigen sahne
mascarpone vanille extrakt oder vanille
zucker sahne stand mittel und wer möchte
noch etwas marmelade
[Musik]
die füllung geht super schnell ihr müsst
einfach nur eure kalte schlagsahne und
die kalte mascarpone zusammen mit dem
vanille extrakt in eure rührschüssel tun
und dann einmal aufschlagen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nach etwa 15 sekunden nachdem sich das
ganze ganz grob vermischt hat geben wir
unser seine stand mittel mit dazu und
lassen das komplett steif schlagen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die fertige füllung gebe ich dann in
meinen spritzbeutel ihr könnt hier
wieder vorne einfach nur die spitze
abschneiden oder eine runde spritzte
verwenden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nun gebe ich auf eine hälfte des
macarons ein tropfen von unserer füllung
und gäbe dann die zweite hälfte drauf
achtet darauf dass sie einigermaßen
gleich groß sind und dann ist der macau
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die variante mit der marmelade ist so
dass wir uns wieder zwei gleich große
macke hälften nehmen und dann ein
tropfen von der füllung drauf geben
anschließend gehen wir noch ein ganz
klein bisschen von der marmelade darüber
und geben den deckel drauf
[Gelächter]
hier finde ich besonders das endergebnis
schön weil man dann ein bisschen noch
dieses farbspiel hat aber das könnt ihr
natürlich vollkommen selbst entscheiden
ihr könnt auch bei der erfüllung
komplett variabel sein ob es nun nutella
ist oder irgendeine ghanas entscheidet
das vollkommen nachgeschmack
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wenn ihr dann alle macarons befüllt habt
sind sie fertig und lagert sie am besten
luftdicht im kühlschrank wegen der seine
füllung und am allerbesten schmecken sie
wenn sie noch ungefähr eine stunde lang
stehen denn dann haben sie in meinen
augen die perfekte konsistenz
falls ihr jetzt auch lust habt diese
leckeren macarons selber herzustellen
dann schaut man in die infobox da stehen
alle weiteren informationen und die
mengenangaben und ich freue mich wenn
ihr beim nächsten mal auch wieder
einschaltet denn dann seht ihr wofür ich
die macarons überhaupt verwendet habe
bis zum nächsten mal auf welches kitchen
[Musik]